[Music]
everything's been going pretty well for
me
the woman I had sex with last night was
a model that I built actually my
girlfriend and I are having a kid in
about seven weeks and I'm really excited
about it but the scariest thing to me
are all the choices you have to make
before the baby even arise like a couple
nights ago my girlfriend came home from
work with this huge book of names we're
trying to narrow down the father one
time I had my therapist come to a show
that was a big mistake
no one heckles like a therapist
therapist heckling is accurate get off
the stage call your dad you won't the
voices in my head are getting louder so
no more volumizing shampoo
I'm always worried something is wrong
with me medically I'm a bit of a
hypochondriac at least according to my
gynecologist I breastfed for way longer
than normal today I was at the grocery
store when I got to the cashier she was
like do you want to donate two dollars
to end world hunger I was like hell yeah
I had no idea we were so close I'm gonna
be a goddamn hero
[Applause]
you know when you join a gang they beat
you up there's a chance I'm in like 30
gangs I had a life-changing experience
but then I had another one and it
changed back through up Catholic we're
still to this day eating the body of
Christ how big was this guy now I'm a
theist but I'm not super atheist like a
lean angel hair pasta before the
rubberband
lobster's ruled the earth
I think the most important thing to
remember when committing a murder
suicide is the order I have a pet
goldfish it's a rescue I also have a dog
sometimes my dog humps my leg so stupid
I had to show him where my butthole is
[Applause]
relax I ended world hunger
[Applause]
did you know if you stick your dick in a
vacuum cleaner and turn it on reverse
they will kick you out of a Sears
[Applause]
every Sears
you